WINDS THAT NCAA CHAMPIONSHIP.
A VERY CLOSE FOR SECOND.
>> AND 11 TIME NCAA ALL-AMERICA
SWIMMING CHAMP, AND WAS AT BOTH
RACES TODAY.
SHE JOINS ME NOW VERY JERRY, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE ANNOUNCER REALLY
WANTED TO TELL US ALL HOW CLOSE
EVERYTHING WAS.
TO LIST WHAT YOU THOUGHT OF HOW
THINGS UNFOLDED.
>> LAURA, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
IT'S ACTUALLY INTERESTING WHEN
YOU INTRODUCE ME YOU USE THE
WORD OUTRAGED, AND WHAT I FELT
WATCHING THIS MORNING THIS
MORNING AND THIS EVENING WAS
GENUINE DEVASTATION AND SADNESS
FOR THE WOMEN THAT ARE BEING
ASKED TO SHOW UP AT THE WOMEN'S
NCAA DIVISION I SWIMMING AND
DIVING CHAMPIONSHIPS, WHICH IS
POSSIBLY THE FASTEST MEAT IN TH
WORLD IF NOT CERTAINLY OUR
COUNTRY, AND TO THEN UNDER THE
BEST OF CIRCUMSTANCES PERFORM
YOUR BEST, GO BEST TIMES, AND
NOW YOU NEED TO DO IT AGAINST A
MALE BODY, YOU NEED TO DO IT AN
EXIT THE POOL SILENTLY AND
GRACEFULLY, AND THEN, I WATCH
THEM GET OUT AND CRY WITH THEIR
COACHES AND THEIR PARENTS
BECAUSE OF THE EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL TURMOIL THAT IT I
TAKING ON THESE WOMEN AND THAT
IS WHAT NEEDS TO BE SAID.
THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR
.
IT IS MORE THAN JUST A SPORT, I
IS MORE THAN USING THE TITLES
WHICH THEY ARE CERTAINLY LOSING.
IT IS ALSO THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISRUPTION THAT IS HAPPENING TO
THEM AND THE LACK OF SUPPORT
THAT THE UNIVERSITIES AND OUR
NCAA IS PROVIDING THEM.
IT IS ABHORRENT TO BE A PART OF.
I EVEN FELT COMPLACENT SITTING
IN THE STANDS TODAY AND I THINK
THAT IS WHY I WANTED TO COME ON
AND DO ANYTHING I COULD TO HELP
MOVE THE NEEDLE AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING WOMEN IN ALL ASPECTS
NOW, AND IN THE FUTURE.
>> I WANT TO JUMP IN AND ASK A
QUESTION.
THAT 10200 LET'S SAY LEAH THOMA
HAS REALLY TRAINED IN BACKSTROKE
, LET'S SAY THE LAST
TWO OR THREE YEARS BEFORE THE
TRANSITION, AND THEN THE
TRANSITION AND COMPETED AGAINST
YOU, WOULD YOUR, AND MEAN IT'S
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION, BUT IT'S
NOT CLEAR, IS IT, THAT YOU WOUL
HAVE BEEN AN ALL-AMERICAN?
YOU MAYBE WOULDN'T HAVE WON AS
MANY CHAMPIONSHIPS AS YOU DID.
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
GET I THINK ABOUT IT ALL THE
TIME.
IT'S NOT HYPOTHETICAL TO THE
WOMEN COMPETING AT THIS MEET IN
2022.
IT'S NOT HYPOTHETICAL IT'S NOT
THEORETICAL, IT IS HAPPENING.
I WATCH GIRLS ON THE SCOREBOARD
GETS NINTH THEY WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO CALL THEMSELVES AT TOP
EIGHT FINALIST AT THE NCAA, I
WATCHED WOMEN THEY GOT 17 TODAY
THAT WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO CALL
THEMSELVES AN ALL-AMERICAN LIKE
I GET TO TODAY BECAUSE I WAS
GIVEN OF FAIR AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN MY SPORTS.
WE GROW UP BEING TOLD THE WORLD
IS UNFAIR, THAT SPORTS PROVIDES
ONE OF THE VERY FEW
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE RELY UPON
AND THAT IS BEING TAKEN AWAY
FROM THEM ALL OF A SUDDEN AND W
ARE ASKING THEM TO LITERALLY
ENDURE IT.
>> WE HAVE TO ROLL, BUT THEY AR
NOT ALLOWED TO SPEAK BECAUSE IF
THEY DO, THEY WILL BE DROPPED
OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY AT DOUBLE
INSULT.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BRAVERY IN SPEAKING OUT